[Music]
for this elimination if somebody buys
immunity it means that they can no
longer be voted out and that would mean
the vote would go towards the other two
people and one of them would have to
leave it has been the consensus that
nobody is going to buy the immunity
because it is so costly like 10 of 250k
is still 25 000
and i feel like if someone used that
then they would just go home the
following elimination anyway
sam and chance both vocalized to me that
they are voting me out so for me right
now my only option is to either a go
home or be
buy immunity
and send sam or chance home
[Music]
i have weird hope that kira is going to
leave and let me and chance go to final
two i don't know why i have that hope
but i do
[Music]
so
[Music]
i
uh
i need to know if it was my vote that
sent me home or if it didn't matter
my gut was screaming that she voted
chance
did i blow it
which is why i thought if chance voted
her and i voted myself then it would be
a tiebreaker and i would have saved
chance and then we would all walk out
and just vote her out
when i put myself in her mind
and realized there were six figures on
the line i get it she needs the money
just as bad as us
and we told her she was going to leave
if she didn't use it and she used it
i feel like i met a lifetime friend with
chance it's weird eight days that's it
but he's just an incredible person he's
lived a rough life i couldn't think of a
better person to win the money
[Music]
[Music]
it's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i did buy immunity
at the cost of sam's stay in the game
and that's the first time where i felt
like i've taken something away from
someone that didn't deserve it i do feel
bad
but i wouldn't be sitting here right now
if it weren't for my decision
sorry
[Music]
uh i feel pretty wretched right now
i know i'm angry so i'm assuming that
sam might be angry as well
i'm definitely sad because he's not here
and i i wanted to be him and i at the
end
to spend that much money
on immunity when i know him and i would
have looked out for her the moment we
got out of these walls
i just chose the person that i thought
needed the money more
i just would rather be in the end with
you
i understand yeah yeah it was the
hardest decision i've
i don't really know if i can say
anything but also like if my friends are
watching at home and i decided to
voluntarily go home like i don't know if
i would have been able to live with that
and not know like what if like
yeah yeah
but it's just all fresh today was a lot
you know it was a lot yeah he didn't die
right exactly exactly yeah
he's he's gonna be successful regardless
of this show
kyra
doesn't understand um sam's situation
she's seeing her point of view but she
also mentioned that she wouldn't be able
to live with herself because of other
people and i thought that was
interesting because it's like i'm not in
this game with other people i'm in this
game with you and i'm annoyed
[Music]
i went over all the possible solutions
in my mind so
i'm just i am upset i'm not gonna not be
upset you know
um
there are some things that were said
about like from both of them that
steered me the wrong way it almost
sounded like chance saying oh we got you
covered like we'll give you anything you
need and for me that was like well
that's not playing the game both of them
voting me out wasn't fair to me i had to
do what was best for myself in that
moment
i really hope you forgive me
i wanted to split it with sam also i
just want to make that clear that i did
yeah
right now we have
still impressive you know 225 000 left
i mean it's still more money than i have
ever had in my life
i really hope chance and i can make
amends because there are two days left
it does worry me because he's so
apprehensive to
talk to me right now but i hope that we
can both mature
and understand that it's still a game
[Music]
for the first time since i've been here
i'm going to have to
i'm gonna have to play a game
i don't know if i can outsmart her she's
very smart so i'm gonna have to call in
all my tools to make sure that i walk
out with the money
hmm
[Music]
chance
[Music]
it's day nine on money game
last night was really difficult kyra not
only sent sam home but she spent more
money in one day than eight of us did on
the first night
chance
hey i'm moving slope i'm here no it's
okay take your time
sorry
my plan is that i'm going to walk away
with all the money
how'd you sleep this looked okay
how did you sleep
this morning i thought chance and i
weren't going to be good today because
it's just been like an emotional
rollercoaster this entire game did you
see my note yeah i did thank you
i felt guilty like i got into my room
and just like started crying so
it's not like
i wanted to i still think we care about
each other and i really do hope that
that care for each other still bleeds
into this next elimination i get it
nature of the game
i wish the game wasn't like that yeah
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
too close
that's where i thought it was gonna be
let's update the wall
[Music]
that still leaves
112 000 each
yeah
like
i'm cool
i don't know about you but i'm cool with
112. no yeah no same chance and i are
both at an odds of just feeling like our
trust is kind of broken
even though we're trying to mend it as
best as we can i feel like it would make
sense if only one of us won
i personally would like it if we both
walked out of here yeah
i mean it
no i mean it too i mean i've meant it
every time that we've said it
i feel like the final elimination could
make things messy it depends on what the
game gives us and that'll determine who
walks away with money and who doesn't
[Music]
it's going to be a long day it already
is
and positive things can be thrown at us
we still have a little less than 24
hours in this game but i'm a little more
hopeful that whatever is thrown at us
isn't going to be scary but who knows
do you remember when i asked you
yesterday if you
split or take it yeah do you still mean
that yes
my only concern is that it's not going
to be that simple
even now with kira i want to avoid
making her promises i just want it to be
that simple it's just like stressing me
out yeah
i understand
the reduction of money didn't really
phase me because that's still over a
hundred thousand dollars each and for me
that's huge i can't even imagine like
what i would do with that much money
i appreciate you saying that
i mean it i understand why you keep
asking but yeah my answer hasn't changed
you're a good person
cura keeps asking me if i would split
she says that it's not because she's
doubting me
but she's asked me i think three times
today so that gives me pause because i
don't know what's in her head
i don't like this game i think if we
can't split she's gonna want to win and
then i won't see any of the money it was
so much fun two days ago
it is not fun now
[Music]
the money you would do so much for
just my personal health but also on top
of that like i haven't been to the
dentist in three years i have at least
that like i'm trying to get out of the
money would help with that i lost my
grandfather kova two months ago i want
to make sure that money is being used
for things that are essential and that
should carry me far in my life
[Music]
good morning
good morning
happy day 10. happy day 10. how do you
feel
all right how are you i'm good i did
that thing where i woke up and then i
was awake for a while and then fell
asleep again
what does today have in store money game
overlords
oh my god
i'm really participating in this money
game because i want to dolly yeah it's
dominant obviously be great but i also
want to push myself i want to prove to
myself that i can do this oh my god
i don't know if i can even fit a bed
i'm doing money game because i thought
this would be a great way to pay off my
student loans and pay for my wedding i
grew up looking like this in nebraska so
i'm used to people just kind of assuming
i'm a [ __ ] upon meeting me
so i'm doing money game for my little
brother and i to just give us a chance
to pursue the arts i don't have an
immediacy for this
like for the surprise and so um i'm
voting for myself tonight and feel free
to do the same
like most people i do have student debt
for college that i can't even
yeah i can't even use a degree
[Music]
i'm doing money game because it seemed
like a good time
i think that you know we could make some
internet memes
and i'm trying to make some money
you know so lightheaded i'm only going
to hit it twice a day so this should
last me i think how much was it i'm
curious two thousand
i'm doing money game because i have a
dog who is blind and she needs surgery
for eight thousand dollars it's crazy
how this game works in a blink of an eye
i'm holding me
my main reason for doing money game is i
was homeless for three and a half years
and i never want to be in a situation
like that again
being somebody that pays rent being a
student and working full-time can be
really difficult
and i just want to be able to enjoy
living my life without having to worry
about finances for a bit
[Music]
you deserve to be here you deserve to be
here
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it is hard watching that bad thing and
seeing why she wanted to be here i was
just like damn like yeah it's hard kind
of looking back and remembering that we
all started from the same place with the
same wish
seeing everybody else it was kind of you
know it was bittersweet because
everyone had the reasons for for wanting
to be here
[Music]
only one person can buy immunity
immunity will go to the highest
will be deducted from the current cash
prize amount
to purchase immunity circle your own
number and write your bid in the
indicated box there is no tiebreaker in
the independence
[Music]
it's still not real to me until until it
happens
would you rather vote for each other or
vote for yourself
i'll go for myself i'll vote for myself
i feel like that fits for today yeah
when i came into this game a hundred
dollars would have helped my current
financial situation so
having 225 000
is huge
huge huge for me
[Music]
whatever happens happens for a reason
and
at the end of the day like i'm still
proud that i made it this far
animation vote begins okay i see you on
the other side
we got this we got this
i absolutely know that i am going to win
money game
[Music]
i trust him
chance has already said several times
that no matter what he would not buy
immunity
which does frighten me if it's a case of
like if we both need to buy immunity to
win
i feel like he might change his mind
a hundred thousand is way more than i
thought i would be working away here
with and
it's still not gonna feel real until it
happens
i've never had more than a couple of
thousand in the bank at one time
it's absolutely a new lease on life for
me just being able to
to take care of myself you know because
i haven't i haven't taken care of myself
in a long time i haven't been able to
[Music]
i want this to be the start of something
new for me i am not going backwards i've
seen what's back there i'm not doing
that again
i'm trusting you chance
six
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to come out of everything that's been
happening in this game in my life and
come out as like a co-winner that's
pretty badass oh my god
i'm excited i'm overwhelmed it still
doesn't feel real um
yeah i'm just i'm blown away oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
i've always wanted a briefcase for the
money right now is the coolest thing is
this real money oh i can't tell
ten years of miserable emotional turmoil
for
you touch it
it's not real to me yet
[Music]
this is this is so worth it
i keep thinking about how happy my
brother would be right now
oh man
i get to tell my sister i'm gonna tell
in person i'm gonna go to the plate i'm
gonna give her the biggest hug
crazy
thank you for my family for believing in
me thank you to my boyfriend for
believing in me thank you to my friends
oh my god
10 days ago walking in here having
extreme second thoughts when it was way
too late to back out right before i
walked in those doors i was thinking i
made the biggest mistake of my life
[Applause]
i had to come away 10 days later
winning
oh i'm so glad i'm so glad i didn't back
out
i'm gonna get my hair done
[Music]
you